آخر موطئ قدم لأمريكا في
أفغانستان يحرسه الآن طالبان.
شاهد طالبان
لقد جئنا إلى مطار كابول لنرى
القفاز الذي يجب أن يمر به الناس ليطيروا
للخارج ،
يمكنك سماع طلقات نارية كل
دقيقتين.
أيها المقاتل ، هل يمكنني أن أسألك سؤالًا
قال لي لتغطية إيماني
لكنه لا يريد التعليق على ذلك
الخندق الذي
يحمل المقاتل يخبرنا أن هذه
المشاهد الفوضوية هي خطأ
أمريكا والسبب في كل هذا هو أمريكا في
أفغانستان انظروا  يقول هؤلاء الأشخاص إن
أمريكا تتصرف بشكل غير عادل تجاههم حقًا
لماذا يكذبون ويخبرونهم
أنه يمكنهم الذهاب إلى أمريكا ، فلماذا لا
يسمحون لهم بالبقاء ومساعدة
بلدهم.
يمكن أن تدخل القاعدة ، نعم
لأنهم يرسلون لي بريدًا إلكترونيًا ،
هل لديك أيضًا أوراق ، نعم ،
لكن لدينا بريدًا إلكترونيًا ويتصلون بي هل
كانت هذه شركة إيطالية؟
لا تريد من هذا الرجل أن يجلدك ،
حسنًا ، شكرًا لك ، شكرًا على
الحشد من حولنا لإظهار
مستنداتهم ،
معسكر فينيكس
للأمريكيين ولا يمكنهم الوصول
إلى هذا المطار ،
هؤلاء مقاتلو طالبان مستاءون قليلاً
منا
قررنا ذلك  غادر واتجه إلى
سيارتنا ، يأخذ المقاتل الأمان من سيارته
ak-
47 ويدفع من خلال الحشد ويبقى خلفه ،
يمكنك أن ترى أن
بعض مقاتلي طالبان هؤلاء قد
ظهروا في الأدرينالين أو لا أعرف
فجأة شحنتان أخريان من طالبان
نحونا ،
يمكنك رؤية مؤخرة بندقيتهم مرفوعة
لضرب المنتجين برنت عندما
يتم إخبار المقاتلين بأن لدينا إذنًا
للإبلاغ عن خفض أسلحتهم والسماح
لنا بالمرور على
ما يرام الآن سنركب
السيارة ويمكنك  تخيل
جيك ، أعني هذا نحن طاقم أخبار ،
من الواضح أننا غربيون وما زلنا
نتعرض لكل أنواع الجنون
إذا كنت أفغانيًا عاديًا تحاول
تجاوز حراس طالبان وتحاول
الوصول إلى المطار.
يعني أنا فقط لا أرى كيف يمكنك
القيام بذلك ، ولا أرى كيف يمكنك
الدخول حقًا إلا إذا كان لديك
نوع من الاتصال أو الاتصال
أو كنت قادرًا على ترتيب شيء
ما بطريقة ما  ولكن كما قلت ، فإن البنية التحتية
ببساطة ليست في مكانها حتى للبدء في
القيام بذلك ، ونتيجة لذلك ، فإن كل
هؤلاء الفقراء يجلسون خارج
المطار لأيام متتالية الآن وهذا
أملهم الأخير ولكن بصراحة
ليس هناك أمل حقيقي